so take your right hand I'm going to
mirror you so we're facing each other
and spin away from me spin backwards so
I'm spinning backwards you're spinning
backwards we're all sitting backwards
together so so far so good I'm imagining
this is no problem
great let's feel it notice we can make
bigger circles smaller circles yeah then
you're going to stop switch sides and
make sure you swing it up in front to
get it going backwards right and also
feel that how it's coming up in front of
you and if you wanted you could throw it
over your shoulder backwards on one side
backwards on the other side backwards on
this side backwards on this side then
you're going to do this you're spinning
backwards I want you to throw the play
over the far shoulder so you're going to
throw it over your left shoulder up and
over and hit yourself then spin
backwards more and you throw it back
over make sure you're going backwards so
if you're not going back as I won't go
over your shoulder you throw it back
over your right shoulder up and over
boom go backwards in on the right side
sometimes it's tough for me to that's
right where I'm mirroring and I'm trying
to remember which what it is for you
okay so you throw it over your over your
left shoulder backwards up and over your
right shoulder spin backwards up and
over your left shoulder spin backwards
up and over your right shoulder spin
backwards then you're going to start as
if you're gonna throw it over your left
shoulder and you miss and if you're if
you miss and relax it'll still be going
backwards then you want to throw it back
over your right shoulder but you miss
and you want to start because what
people will so I'm going to do is it'll
do this so I'll switch the forwards so
you want to make sure you start as if
you're going to do this but you kind of
miss and you come back as if you're
going to do this
but you miss and pretty soon you're
going over and myths up and miss
backwards at the left shoulder backwards
at the right shoulder backwards at the
left shoulder backwards at the right
shoulder and you're gonna play with this
until you can just cross backwards and
some of you that might come quickly
other people it often takes a while it
takes you know you might need to play
ten minutes now take a break another ten
minutes
this will ultimately be the foundation
of so much of what you're gonna learn so
you want to get really relaxed with it
and again I'm letting it be my whole
body I'm shifting the way to my feet my
hips are turning my shoulders are moving
and the poise crossing side to side and
some I know some of you are going to
have this habit of switching the
forwards so keep checking if you can hit
you in the feet you've switched the
forwards make sure you're going
backwards once that's working just like
forwards you're gonna learn you can
learn to do it higher and lower and
really wide side to side or really
narrow or letting your body turn a lot
can your body stand very still
just relax and playing with the movement
and then beginning to sort of move
around and just loosen up and keep
checking is a boy going backwards if you
hit your shoulder you're going backwards
so this is one of those points where
don't bother progressing until this is
smooth until you're really relaxed with
this because if this isn't happening
smoothly the next lessons will be tough
so just keep coming back to this maybe
tomorrow come back to this get this
really into your muscle memory until
this is happening with each hand and
I'll see you with the other hand until
this you can chew bubblegum and it keeps
working all right you can put music on
close your eyes and it keeps working you
want to get this deeply deeply feeling
comfortable and where you're not
switching the forward so you're
definitely going backwards and you can
tell because this is forwards do it
forwards switch do it backwards
switch your forwards switch do it
backwards then it's time to move on to
the next lesson and if this is really
natural we'll be doing you'll do great